[Música]
mientras la unión europa espera a
empezar la vacunación a partir del 27 de
diciembre américa latina está rezagada
en la carrera por las vacunas chile
argentina y ecuador anunciaron avances
en sus campañas de vacunación masivas se
encontraron con un gran lote de dosis lo
analizaremos con un directivo en la
universidad johns hopkins
emanuel macrón dio positivo por kobe 19
y se aisló en el palacio del elíseo
desde donde seguirá trabajando luego de
que el presidente francesa anunciará a
su contagio varios líderes que tuvieron
contacto con él se han puesto en
cuarentena y algunos se han dado
negativo a la prueba
liberados más de 300 niños secuestrados
en nigeria tras el ataque a una escuela
adjudicado por el grupo yihadista boko
haram un funcionario señaló que ninguno
de los encontrados había fallecido y que
los menores liberados se encuentran en
buen estado de salud
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria empezamos en eeuu el comité
de la administración de medicinas y
alimentos votó para recomendar la
autorización del uso de emergencia de la
vacuna de moderna por lo que la decisión
de autorizar la podría tomarse en los
próximos días mientras que en américa
latina se dan los primeros pasos para la
vacunación contra el kobe 19 chile
iniciará su campaña antes del fin de año
con 20 mil dosis del fármaco de facer y
bayonne tec argentinas esperar recibir
300.000 dosis de la vacuna rusa el 24 de
diciembre y ecuador se empezará a
aplicar dosis a sus ciudadanos en enero
y para impulsar la compra y distribución
de las vacunas el banco interamericano
de desarrollo anunció que movilizará mil
millones de dólares extra en ayuda a
países de la región
es por ello que enlazamos con el médico
epidemiólogo carlos castrillo salgado él
es directivo en la universidad johns
hopkins
gracias doctor por esta comunicación al
menos una quinta parte de la población
mundial podría no tener acceso a una
vacuna hasta 2022 este dato debe
preocupar a nuestra región cómo está la
situación de las vacunas en américa
latina' cuáles son los mejores casos y
cuáles son los focos rojos
muy buenas noches gracias por la
invitación en realidad en la región de
las américas está en mejores condiciones
en otros países particularmente áfrica
y países de poco desarrollo en la región
de las américas además del banco el bid
el banco interamericano existe la
presión para américa de la salud que
hizo ya acuerdos desde hace
a unos meses con kóvacs y como usted
sabe cómo es la alianza estratégica que
está manejando actualmente los
escenarios posibles para poder superar
el escenario que usted está marcando de
un riesgo en este momento le llamamos
riesgo de que a un porcentaje importante
de la población mundial tenga un acceso
que hasta probablemente un año que
posterior a los países desarrollados sin
embargo también tengo que mencionar en
este momento están haciendo consulta
especial en ginebra con asesores
especiales de el grupo de citibank de
citibank a que están asesorando sobre
todos los posibles escenarios tanto
negativos como como abordarlos doctor y
qué tan preparados están los gobiernos
latinoamericanos para los desafíos
logísticos que presentan algunas vacunas
y la necesidad de inyectar dos dosis o
de conservarlas a temperaturas muy bajas
este es un proceso bastante complicado
por lo cual muchos de los países están
esperando también tener acceso a otras
vacunas
una de las consideraciones importantes
es que en este momento los países como
inglaterra eeuu que algunos de los
países árabes han tenido mucho éxito en
la compra de la vacuna de facer o
moderna y esto está considerando todas
los insumos que tienen en ellos gran
capacidad en américa latina es posible
otras vacunas entre las de astrazéneca
se espera que pueda tener un mejor y un
mejor programa de implementación ya que
no requiere a las características de
refrigeración que tiene facer si en ese
sentido se espera que la vacuna rusia la
vacuna de astrazéneca y también se ha
aprobado en la mayoría de los países de
américa latina hasta ahora si muchas
gracias doctor carlos castrillo salgado
por esta comunicación por su análisis él
es médico epidemiólogo también directivo
en la universidad john hopkins y nos
vamos a europa porque el presidente de
francia de manuel macrón dio positivo
por coronavirus causando revuelo tanto
en la política francesa como la europea
marinas ardilla nos explica por qué
el cob y 19 llegó al palacio del elíseo
con el positivo del presidente francés
emmanuel macrón según presidencia es muy
probable que macro se contagiase durante
el consejo europeo la semana pasada
nadie ni siquiera el presidente de la
república está a salvo de esto que pagan
u2 es ahora el líder del ejecutivo
francés se encuentra en aislamiento
junto a su esposa brigitte quien dio
negativo y ha cancelado todos los
próximos viajes oficiales o topes online
en cuanto al presidente de la república
es un ejemplo para todos los franceses
se aisló al menor síntoma eso es
exactamente lo que decimos a todos los
franceses de fase tras la confirmación
del positivo por kobe 19 de macrón se
llevó a cabo un estricto rastreo
numerosos jefes de estado y funcionarios
se realizaron la prueba entre ellos el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez el mandatario portugués antonio
costa o el primer ministro francés yann
castex todos ellos negativos pese a esto
varios de los políticos y funcionarios
que mantuvieron estrecho contacto con
macrón en los últimos días entrarán en
cuarentena durante una semana el lunes
durante una conferencia en parís macrón
de un polémico apretón de manos al jefe
de la ocde
mexicano josé ángel gurría el jefe de
estado fue uno de los primeros en
adoptar los saludos a distancia y rara
vez fue visto sin mascarilla pero según
los críticos mostraba signos de haber
bajado la guardia
nigeria confirmó que los más de 300
estudiantes secuestrados en el noroeste
del país fueron liberados en una
operación en la que los menores quedaron
ilesos este viernes serán llevados con
sus familiares aunque el hecho no calma
la inseguridad generalizada y la
preocupación por el extremismo de la
nación africana nos cuenta más
yanira al gómez muñoz
tras seis días de secuestro ya están a
salvo los más de 300 menores raptados en
la escuela masculina del estado de
katsina así lo aseguraron las
autoridades nigerianas cuyas fuerzas
militares liberaron a los alumnos
atacados el viernes con kalashnikovs y
retenidos luego en un bosque en el
estado vecino de zamfara y si no a todos
creo que hemos recuperado a la mayoría
de los niños y ya se ha difundido que
todos han sido hallados ilesos y serán
trasladados desde la zona forestal de
sant para el viernes los examinaremos y
serán los arreglos para unirlos con sus
familias
se ignora si aún quedan otros niños
secuestrados del mismo modo que no se ha
confirmado que el grupo boko haram que
se atribuyó el ataque en un vídeo en el
que varios menores pedían ayuda haya
sido el causante si bien no hay duda de
que es el mayor rapto masivo desde el
chico de 2014 que trauma a nigeria con
112 de 276 alumnas todavía desaparecidas
este último duele además por haber
acontecido en el estado natal del
mandatario del país
nuestra administración es plenamente
consciente de la responsabilidad que
tenemos de proteger la vida y la
propiedad de todos los nigerianos les
pido a los nigerianos que sean pacientes
y justos con nosotros mientras
enfrentamos los desafíos de la seguridad
la economía y la corrupción no vamos a
acceder aunque el gobierno y policía
buscan garantizar más seguridad en las
escuelas con un aumento del resguardo
privado las familias exigieron también
este jueves contundencia ya sea frente a
boko haram o contra otros criminales
esto en una nigeria en la que el
yihadismo es extendido por todo el norte
del territorio con dos ataques el último
mes un territorio en el que el líder
islamista del grupo abubakar shekau se
habría reforzado junto a otros grupos y
finalizamos en eeuu donde llegó la
primera gran tormenta de nieve de la
temporada de nueva york que dejó al
noreste cubierto de blanco estableciendo
récords incluso en algunas áreas con su
mayor nevada después de varios años así
amaneció la gran manzana en un momento
crítico de la pandemia aunque los
funcionarios ya informaron que las
nevadas no interrumpirán a la vista
las vacunas informaron también
condiciones peligrosas en las carreteras
de varios estados estadounidenses lo que
provocó decenas de accidentes
pues con mucho cuidado del cobi 19 y de
las condiciones extremas nos despedimos
siga con nosotros y disfrute de su noche
aquí en france 24
[Música]